[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsque vous voyez ça s'est passé aux
bermudes le 10 octobre dernier à des
journalistes de partout dans le monde
qui sont allés chez appleby a publié la
firme d'où provient une grande partie
des documents départ des spurs et il
avait des questions à poser à albi mais
gino cette fuite là ça soulève des
questions pour plusieurs gouvernements
dont le nôtre
oui parce que dans les documents qu'on a
trouvé on remarque qu'il ya eu certains
contacts entre des hauts fonctionnaires
canadiens et puissant lobby qui défend
l'utilité des petits pays comme les
bermudes dans l'économie mondiale et
vous allez voir que quand on parle de
paradis fiscaux le discours public du
canada n'est pas toujours le même en
privé
[Musique]
2009 nous sommes à la réunion des
leaders du g20 à londres
plusieurs chefs d'état montre du doigt
les paradis fiscaux est venu le temps du
secret bancaire est révolu les centres
financiers offshore dont l'attrait
repose en grande partie sur la
confidentialité voit une menace à leur
survie ceux qui les défendent contre
attaque canadien du cabinet fait partie
de ceux là
d'ailleurs il n'aime visiblement pas
qu'on appelle ses petits pays des
paradis fiscaux c'est péjoratif
ça crée la confusion chez les gens comme
si d'avoir un faible taux d'imposition
c'est mal comme l'évasion fiscale est
basé à londres et les paris nice people
nous le ferons découvrir un peu plus
mais braquons d'abord les projecteurs
sur 2013
dans son budget le ministre canadien des
finances s'en prend à l'évasion fiscale
on annonce des mesures mais le
mécontentement populaire contre une
évasion fiscale s'intensifie la ici à
alger le consortium international des
journalistes d' enquête publie les
offres charles x
une première série de reportages basée
sur des documents confidentiels
provenant de paradis fiscaux
on y trouve des courriels et des
documents officiels de toutes sortes
concernant les sociétés offshore blonde
de choc et mondial dont les jours qui
suivent le ministre flaherty effectué un
voyage aux bermudes paradis fiscal
réputé une semaine après l'un des plus
gros scandale fiscal allemand
la visite du ministre aux bermudes
mettra l'accent sur les liens d'affaires
entre nos deux pays
quelques mois plus tard le premier
ministre david cameron est l'hôte du
sommet du g8
et il propulse à l'avant scène l'enjeu
de la transparence dans le secteur
financier soit effective 2013 et à une
année marquante parce que le premier
ministre britannique david cameron
croyais alors important de s'attaquer à
la corruption est issu du milieu des ong
ces organisations non gouvernementales
qui font pression depuis des années pour
qu'on puisse connaître les véritables
propriétaires des compagnies et fred
pour lutter contre la pauvreté il faut
lutter contre la corruption et les
compagnies coquille anonyme facilite
cette corruption en chine en 2013
les ong comptent donc sur un allié de
taille david cameron prêche par
l'exemple en annonçant ses intentions
pour le royaume uni
il s'est engagé à l'occasion du g8 à
instaurer au royaume-uni registre public
des propriétaires d'entreprises playon
le chèque
nous favorisons l'agenda de monsieur
cameron
évidemment le construire nos provinces
pour la professeur de fiscalité marois
risky le canada prend alors un
engagement public qu'il devra respecter
le canada indique allait participer de
façon active contre toutes les formes de
stratagèmes fiscaux ainsi que pour avoir
plus de transparence
gino moi j'aimerais en savoir davantage
sur reach est avocat canadien et celui
qui aime pas trop l'expression paradis
fiscaux bon monsieur ries travaille déjà
à l'époque pour ce lobby qui s'appelle
international financial center sport
pour faire plus court ailleurs six
forums
ce forum regroupe une douzaine de grands
cabinets qui oeuvrent dans l'état dit
fiscaux d y en a pour dix fait partie de
la f6 forum maintenant vous allez voir
tous les efforts de lobby qu'ils ont
menées pour s'assurer de préserver le
secret dans les paradis fiscaux dans les
semaines précédant le sommet du g8 de
reach cry et la f6 forme sous la lame
dans ce message révélé par les paradise
papers les ong ont mis sur pied une
vaste campagne pour encore réclamé la
fin des paradis fiscaux britanniques
nous étions en consultation étroite avec
le gouvernement britannique
et avec d'autres politiciens
publiquement nous avons aussi mené des
campagnes en invitant les gens à signer
des pétitions pour retirer cette
campagne des ong menace l'existence même
de certains paradis fiscaux les ong
veulent annihiler les centres financiers
internationaux britanniques
il progresse rapidement vers leur but
pendant des semaines la f6 forum
contactera et rencontrera des
représentants de divers pays
mais au terme de ces jeux de coulisses
david cameron semble s'être rendu aux
arguments des ong la vie que mènent au
royaume uni cette transparence passera
notamment par un registre public des
propriétaires d'entreprises les
informations de la fuite nous montre
comment la f6 fort méritée surveilleront
ce que feront d'autres pays comme le
canada car pour eux l'enjeu de la
confidentialité est centrale
trois jours après le sommet du g8
des documents nous révèle que richie a
rencontré un haut fonctionnaire canadien
de passage à londres
rituel et rencontré le représentant du
canada pour le g20 qui est aussi sous
ministre du commerce international
ceux-ci ministre canadien c'est sans
heaven cana be ce qui étonne c'est ce
que la f6 forum retient de la rencontre
les canadiens hésitent à participer au
programme de transparence du royaume uni
mais avec les résultats du g8
ils se sentent obligés de l'étudier je
rappelle qu'en 2013
le gouvernement canadien a clairement
dit lors d'une réunion du g8 à ce
moment-là qu'il allait faire la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux
la lutte pour avoir plus de transparence
mais clairement le discours est tenu
publiquement diffèrent largement des
discussions privées le sous-ministre
kennedy nous a expliqué qu'à l'époque
ces fonctions-là venait régulièrement à
rencontrer des groupes de tous horizons
incluant aussi des ong
par ailleurs la fuite nous apprend que
richie a rencontré une nouvelle fois le
sous ministre en janvier 2014
cette fois au canada puis au mois de
mars suivant un autre haut fonctionnaire
canadien s'adresse par téléphone ou
membres de la r6 forum qui sont réunis
dans ses bureaux au coeur de londres
ce qui me préoccupe c'est déjà un haut
fonctionnaire qui participent dans la
stratégie pour s'assurer que le canada
n'embarque pas dans la balle qui est
vers la transparence c'est hautement
préoccupantes et à ce moment ci s'est
même de se demander pour qu'ils
travaillent pour le grand canadien ont
pour fc
si l'on se fie aux résumés des idées que
ce canadien aurait proposé lors de cet
appel
en voici une qui a de quoi surprendre
propager l'idée que les centres
financiers internationaux sont des
lubrifiants pour le commerce
international ce qui réduit la pauvreté
ces paradis fiscaux serait donc des
lubrifiants
c'est d'ailleurs un des arguments de
l'arrière 6 programmes expliqué ici par
son responsable des communications
en quoi vous voyez vous les centres
financiers internationaux comme des
lubrifiants
ils servent de plate-forme fiscales qui
permettent de déplacer des capitaux à
travers le monde sans payer d'impôts
plusieurs fois c'est pas des lubrifiants
ce sont des cancers
l'avocat a rétorqué a refusé de répondre
à nos questions en rappelant que ce
qu'il fait pour ses clients comme la nfc
forum est confidentiel il rappelle aussi
qu'il est dûment inscrits comme le bis
en grande bretagne or il n'était pas
inscrit au registre canadien lorsqu'il a
rencontré le sous ministre kennedy
selon les informations obtenues auprès
du commissariat au lobbying du canada
syrie turquie à discuter de changements
aux lois et règlements politiques ou
programme du gouvernement du canada
sans être inscrit au registre cela
pourrait être illégale influencer le
gouvernement canadien n'a jamais été un
objectif de la fin et je ne me rappelle
d'aucune discussion à ce sujet là
pourtant dans ces documents internes la
r6 forum se propose d'influencé des
gouvernements du g20 dont fait partie le
canada
[Musique]
influence tout pas riches profitent
aussi d'autres tribune pour débattre de
ses idées sur les registres publics
comme lors de cette conférence à londres
en 2014
l'idée derrière ce projet serait
d'afficher des avoirs des gens dans un
registre majeur pour le monde entier
pourquoi at on besoin de ça il faut
pouvoir suivre l'argent se souvient bien
de ce débat il y avait été invité et la
vérité inconfortable sait que trop
souvent cet argent abouti dans des
comptes de banques secret les centres
financiers internationaux peuvent
certainement joué un rôle pour faciliter
les investissements mais il ne devrait
pas permettre le secret le secret
facilite la corruption le film n'a rien
contre des registres qui peuvent être
consultées par les autorités mais pas
par le public mais qui est si important
mais pour des voeux de maintenir les
dernières fuites médiatiques montre
toute l'importance d'avoir des documents
publics les panama people vont tout
changer parce qu'ils ont vraiment permis
d'exposer l'ampleur de l'utilisation des
compagnies coquille dans le blanchiment
d'argent
si ce type d'information n'est pas
dévoilé alors rien n'empêchera ce genre
de comportement youth can happen avez
vous l'impression ces fuites journée les
cycles sont nécessaires elles sont
vitales sont plus que essentielle si
nous on avait jamais eu ces chutes johan
stick
aujourd'hui la tour ne penserai qu'à
canada fait bonne figure que le canada
est un bon élève dans la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale pour marwa rizki le
canada n'a toujours pas donné suite aux
initiatives de transparence comme celles
prises par les britanniques
le canada a tergiversé pendant des
années à dire on étudie la question
c'est pas compliqué mettre un registre
public en place c'est pas du tout
compliqué ça prend 12 la volonté
politique
après la pause d'autres révélations des
périodes des spurs
[Musique]